both
tune in for yourself as well as for
society at large
and investigate if you
have a belief about yourself
that follows a line of thinking like
i am unworthy
or i need validation
i will be happy
peaceful at home
when i attain some sort of
material possession relationship
or i am unlovable is another one
the subconscious
of the individual end of the
civilization is
difficult to investigate because it's
not on the surface of your experience
for example the only reason why i
understand this now is because it was
pointed out to me
by bentino masaro also by
mark haynin
and it's also pointed out by raw
from the law of one where by knowing
yourself and accepting yourself can you
actually become the creator
can you actually truly dissolve
all of the conditioning that you've
subconsciously picked up throughout your
life
to fully
be god and to see god
everywhere
and to just be the infinite oneness that
you've been the whole time
but that all of the conditioning and
subconscious
and psychology and personality
has been blocking you and creating ego
and separation
and cloudiness so that you can't
actually
fully merge with that godson
and so identify where this
core lack belief or weakness is for you
because now i'm able to see it in other
people i'm able to see it in society at
large people
carry around like a [ __ ] massive
piece of luggage on their backs
that weighs 50 pounds everywhere they go
they carry this around because they're
not free
all it requires is for you to drop the
luggage
but in order to drop the luggage you
have to go through
a process of turning inwards
you have to actually look at the
subconscious conditioning that you
picked up
and provide it with that love and
acceptance
that then lets it dissolve and enables
you to transcend it and shift into these
higher frequencies
so here in this visualization you're
playing
a game of chess at a lower frequency
what's happening is that you have a lack
belief
of some sort where you're unworthy or
you're unlovable
or that you need validation from other
people
once i get my rolex or my yacht
then i will get all of these hot women
and then i will feel
whole
only when i attain
my doctor degree will i finally
feel whole
only when i finally meet the love of my
life
and i get married and have kids will i
be whole
so sometime when you were a kid maybe
you were five years old
and your immigrant parents told you that
you have to [ __ ] become a doctor
or you're gonna ruin our family lineage
and so you've been carrying that like a
50-pound piece of luggage your whole
life
or another one is that maybe you were
told
that if you don't have
a great wife or husband and three kids
that you're gonna be a
disappointment to the family
and so now you carry around this 50
pound piece of luggage on your back
saying that if i don't find my perfect
spouse and have three kids with them
then i'm going to be a disappointment to
my family
i've been looking at let's say in this
example
all of these instagram pages that have
yachts and rolexes
and hot women in bikinis and if that's
my input stream every single day
i'm subconsciously programming myself to
not
feel whole or complete until i get a
material possession
like a watch or a boat
and do you really think that any of the
women that come onto that boat are truly
going to love you
same thing with the sports car
so now you have to recognize that you're
playing this game this chess game you
picked up some [ __ ] when you were
five years old 10 years old
that your parents or society at large
delivered into your subconscious
and now you have this little section of
neural architecture inside of
yourself that this
little package of neural architecture is
what is perpetuating this
core lack belief or weakness around
subconsciously around i am not worthy
until i have this
i need validation to feel whole i need
money and fame to feel free and to feel
peaceful and to feel happy and so that's
what you get in this little
chess board of manifestation
and you're playing to be seen you're
playing to be worthy
and so what we're asking you to do in
this process of admitting defeat
is we're asking you to knock over the
king
when you tip over the king it enables
you to shift
from the [ __ ] subconscious
conditioning
from personhood to godhood so you sh
in this process of tipping over the king
you're surrendering and admitting defeat
it enables you to shift from the person
to the god
to i am already always worthy i am the
god son
my cup is always 100 full
and specifically mark has been great at
teaching this in his accept yourself
program
you can find the link in the bottom left
corner of this graphic as well as
in the bio below
you have to surrender playing the game
of chess
you truly have to surrender there's no
other way
because coming from the place of i will
be seen
is a lot different than coming from the
place of
i'm already a hundred percent full baby
you see the huge [ __ ] difference one
of them is coming from this lower
vibrational
frequency of lack
and the other one is coming from this
highest vibrational frequency of
sunlight
i'm already a hundred percent full baby
not one compliment or insult is gonna
affect my 100
fullness and that also plays deeply into
this buddhist concept of emptiness as
well
because you're not allowing these
external concepts
of compliments or insults to affect your
100 percent fullness
already because you're becoming
more of a masterful ninja at emptiness
you have to surrender fully admit defeat
fully to your core lack belief you have
to look
inward look inward what happened when
you were five years old what happened
when you were 10 years old
and what have you been carrying as a
[ __ ] subconscious conditioned belief
that now you're trying to prove yourself
worthy to your family friends and
civilization
and surrender that [ __ ] game
surrender it drop it
as soon as you begin the process of
surrendering and dropping the game
admitting defeat
your liberated into this space of
openness
that you've never felt before
and what it is is it's this freedom this
indescribable freedom that you're
transmuted into
the cloudiness of the game of chess that
you were playing
dissolves and what's left is this
radiant sunlight that was there the
whole time
but that you were never sensitive or
subtle enough to detect
because you were constantly fighting to
be seen or to be worthy
in the chess game of the mainstream
subconscious conditioned personhood
so make the shift by admitting defeat
and surrendering
to your bs core lack belief you have to
identify what it is first
and then tell yourself that i will not
be seen
i will never be seen i will never be
worthy
so what
it's a lower frequency chess game so
what
i'm done with that false belief
it's true for that lower frequency but
it's
false for my truest identity which is i
am already 100 always
full whole the god son
and so create that shift for yourself
meditate on that process what was it
look back what was it when you were five
when you were ten
what is it that's permeating in culture
unfollow and unsubscribe to all of the
materialist
[ __ ] accounts that you follow
none of those things will make you happy
and leverage these types of
visualizations these types of maps
to help you
accelerate your process of shifting from
the person to
god from shifting from your subconscious
conditioned beliefs to the 100
always already whole god son and
go and enter into marx accept yourself
program where he guides you through the
process
of admitting defeat to these core lack
beliefs and weaknesses
so that you can open up the space for
the shift into this 100
always already whole infinite oneness
that you have been
the whole time but that you haven't been
subtle enough to detect
the sun is always [ __ ] shining always
be this layer of cloudiness where you're
fighting for yachts and rolexes
and the spouse that's going to make you
whole
is what's clouding your perception
100 radically love and accept that
subconscious conditioning
and then transcend the living [ __ ] out
of it
all right so there are some more
aspects to this that i'd like to discuss
which is let's go to this one
so in this one we're going to talk about
auto worthiness so these are
all aspects to the same
thing of admitting defeat to this core
lack belief
and merging with the god son so for
example
in my life i've been fighting for my mom
and uncle to validate me as being worthy
to feel our immigration was successful
and so i'm perpetually waiting for my
mom and uncle to tell me something
like hey good job you know you've made
us proud because now our immigration is
successful because you're a doctor or
you're a lawyer or you have a hundred
thousand dollars a year
or you have um some sort of pictures of
mainstream celebrities
or whatnot you own a house now you have
a wife and kids now
and this was especially compounded after
dropping out of college to pursue what
felt like bigger goals
furthermore watching my relatives
friends in the community at large
inquire into my journey i thought how
can i prove myself worthy to them
so you see now after this process
especially of doing something quote
different and dropping out of college
now you have some other people that are
your friends in your community
that are like hey this guy was supposed
to be a doctor he was supposed to be a
lawyer
and now he's dropped out of college
let's see if his life ends up being a
disaster
or if he ends up making something of
himself and so now
you're like i need to prove myself
worthy to all these people
so what will it take to be validated how
much money how much fame how many
subscribers are followers
how many pictures of me with celebrities
getting likes
another rolex or another boat or another
sports car
or i need a hotter wife or i need uh
i need another sheet of paper that
confirms or validates
my level of intelligence
when will my chase for points be
complete when will i finally be seen as
worthy by my mom my uncle my peers
and so in this case you're going through
a similar process at these lower
frequencies of personhood
and so recognize what is the subtlest
part of your subconscious conditioning
and give it that love light awareness
to enable you to liberate yourself from
it but you have to identify it first and
to radically love and accept it
in order for it to dissolve for you to
liberate yourself into merging with the
god son
so during my mom and uncle's recent
visit
to l.a i pressed them both to see
themselves as god sees an
infinite oneness
it is arrogant and out of balance to
press
individuals to make leaps in their
understanding because
everything is perfect as it is and all
awaken in their own time
nobody could shake me awake five years
ago i just had to crawl my way to truth
incrementally recognizing the kingdom of
god
that was inside the whole time
i uncovered myself as already whole like
a full cup
being alive is auto worthiness
being alive is auto worthiness a good
analogy is tipping the king over
surrendering the chess game of seeking
validation outside of oneself
thanks pentino and that was the graphic
visualization we just went over
so stop trying to press other
individuals to see as you see to see as
god sees
stop trying to do that it's arrogant
everything's perfect as it is
everyone awakens in their own time
just because you're the spiritually
privileged and you awaken to infinite
oneness
doesn't mean you need to go like a
martyr and start overzealously shouting
to everybody that it's infinite oneness
be patient
the time will come when more and more
people will see that you're connected
and merged with that god son
and they will inquire hey
i saw that video about the subconscious
conditioning
and i'm wondering if you can help me
identify my corlac belief
people will come to you
you're not expecting any fruits this is
karma yoga don't expect
any fruits at all just uniquely express
yourself from a place of purity
of shepherding the infinite oneness to
awaken
and naturally
these individuations of that infinite
oneness will come
and you will help them because they are
you
expressed as individuated fractals of
that one infinite intelligence
and look at yourself because
where you were at five years ago nobody
could deliver a message to you
that would get you to change you've just
had to
incrementally go through your own
process
and there have been catalysts that have
come and influenced you
but not the process of shaking somebody
awake
nobody could have done it to me five
years ago
and remember that when you do merge with
this god son it's like
feeling that you're a full cup all the
time it's like
feeling that being alive is auto
worthiness and so when you look around
at the individuals and the collective
and you see that there's this
this feeling of lacking worthiness
that that's the number one thing that
you're called to that's why the buddha
talked about compassion
you feel loving kindness to the entire
creation because you've merged with it
you are one with it
so now you look at these individuated
expressions of that one infinite
intelligence and all you want to do
is help them recognize that they're
already 100
worthy as they [ __ ] are and help them
go through this process of knowing and
accepting themselves
my life is now dedicated to helping
others seeking this understanding which
can most easily be seen in the play of
an innocent child
or the creation of our universe this is
all god it's a manifestation of infinity
i was trapped in identifying myself as
small rather than the whole picture
which is the essence of the entire
spiritual journey realigning oneself to
the already always free and worthy
nature of
infinity god fractaled out as
individuals at play with itself
there is only one infinite creator and
we are it
so again when you look at the innocence
of a child
or the creation of our universe you're
feeling the essence of purity
you're feeling the essence of infinity
you're feeling the essence of
unconditional love the entire creation
or an innocent child
is the essence of that unconditional
love light unity that we
are
and the essence of the entire spiritual
journey is to
make the shift from that separate
conditioned subconscious
personhood with lack beliefs to the
always
already whole free god's son infinite
oneness
that's the whole spiritual journey
cool so there's that one and these are
just some recent posts
on uh on instagram
so there's that one on auto worthiness
being alive is auto worthiness
and then this is more on dissolving
subconscious conditioning
a large part of liberation is looking at
one's subconscious
i've constantly marketed to my peers
that i'm different leaving college
moving to silicon valley pursuing truth
what was my intention this is where
we're full of [ __ ]
this is where 10 000 layers of
self-deception prevent us from shining
awareness on the subconscious
so what the [ __ ] was my intention when i
was like i'm gonna leave
ah i'm pursuing truth ah why are you
guys stuck
in the small little hometown what was
your intention when you were saying
those things
because i know that my intention was not
pure 10 years ago when i was saying
those things
sure a part of it was seeking something
that was greater than that hometown
but it also wasn't necessarily fully
pure
because there was still some sort of
separation there was still
a good amount of the lack belief is i
will prove to you
all that i am worthy by leaving this
small town
and by pursuing something greater
and to truly look at your root intention
perpetually is how to purify yourself
more to the god state and less from the
personhood
so you have to look perpetually at where
you're coming from
and that will show you the juxtaposition
of when you're coming from wholeness
from purity from infinite oneness versus
when you're coming from separation from
personhood
so another way to view this is why do
you write what you write in your
instagram bio
when eyeballs look at the words what do
you aim to evoke
i can create an ai that parses instagram
captions running natural language
processing and sentiment analysis to
decipher where you're coming from
are your captions look at me or
i'm your servant
are your captions trying to tell people
to look at how cool you are to for
validation
or are your captions about i'm providing
you with something
valuable here i'm your servant
and i hope that what i provide to you
really helps you
and i can write an ai
that does nlp natural language
processing sentiment analysis to parse
through these instagram bios and
captions
and twitter posts and facebook posts and
tick tock
videos and all this stuff we can use
computer vision to watch
videos on youtube as well to learn about
these things
and we can tell when you're coming from
a place of separation
versus when you're coming from a place
of unity from oneness
and this is the key this is the key this
is the entire spiritual journey
when are your words coming from
separation versus when are they coming
from oneness
when are they coming from being whole
versus when are they coming from a lack
gradually as we turn inward shining the
light of awareness on our ego
distortions our subconscious releases
the need to seek validation and
worthiness
this process empties us of our stuff
which was unknowingly running our lives
and creates the space for the ineffable
miracle of transmutation
the shift is when you no longer look at
people who've seen your instagram story
for validation
but rather to each viewer you think i
hope this helps you
so as you turn inward you
melt away the subconscious egoic
distortions
you release the need to seek validation
worthiness because you've merged with
the god son
you're now emptying out your stuff
you're emptying this small s self
which was unknowingly running your life
on the chess board of manifestation
trying to be seen or validated or worthy
and now you're creating the space for
this ineffable miracle of transmutation
which is sacrificing the separate person
into
infinite oneness to god's son and so the
shift is when you look at the people
that have watched
your story or the viewer counts on the
video instead of viewing it like oh 100
people have watched 200 people have
watched
yay instead of like that view it like i
wonder
out of all these hundred people i wonder
each
of them how this content helped their
life
and if i can continue serving them in
any other way
truly that's the shift
it's not a hit of dopamine for
validation anymore
but it's coming from a place of
wholeness and going
how can i serve this infinite
intelligence awakening to its true
nature
that's it
so help life recognize itself as
infinite oneness
this is what is meant by shepherding by
serving
purely as a mirror
where you're completely empty of
yourself
you're empty of the need to be validated
you're empty of the need to be
seen because you're already the god
son purely radiating that so now
you just non-attachedly shepherd
life recognizing itself as infinite
oneness aka
awakening to itself
so
here's another simple exercise
deconstructing your identity investigate
the string of symbols
ascribed to you at birth like jackson j
a j-a-c-k-s-o-n seven symbols strung
together to name a piece of life or
john j-o-h-n four symbols for naming a
piece of life or sarah
s-a-r-a four symbols for a piece of life
then fortifications are built by this
piece of life to ensure that jackson is
safe
sarah is safe i need to make
fortifications
time is invested in ensuring jackson is
validated as being worthy by other
pieces of life so what happens when we
deconstruct this identity
what happens when we see ourselves as
already whole rather than lacking
an invitation to play
when you see yourself as separate
and lacking you're going to seek
validation and worthiness from other
people
when you see yourself as the
four symbols of s.a.r.a sarah or
john john and
you see yourself as a separate
individual that has no affiliation
to life itself that
is so separate from life itself with its
fortification walls
that inevitably it's going to undergo
processes of seeking externally for
validation for wholeness
it's not going to be aware of its
subconscious conditioning
and so your job as sarah or as john or
as
atlas for example for me was to take
these five
characters atlas and to decondition and
deconstruct myself from them
so what's left nothing emptiness john
or sarah are no longer their little four
symbols that string together to name
their piece of life
they've liberated themselves from it
then you can include it properly so
you're no longer attached to your name
now you recognize yourself as a
decentralized one
intelligence that's infinite that's at
play here in this universe
and then you can say okay cool so now i
can
in a non-attached way in an already
worthy and whole way
i can re-adopt atlas as people need
they can use that to describe this piece
of life
you have to go through these processes
of deconstructing
decentralizing your identity in order
for you to
properly harmonically
play in this creation and so here's
another way you decentralize your
identity every subatomic particle is a
satoshi
a bundle of satoshi's we've symbolized
as
j-o-r-d-a-n jordan which
constructs fortifications of identity
which reinforces separation
when this bundle of satoshis is
decentralized it begins identifying
itself as all bitcoin
life is a decentralized play of one
infinite intelligence
so in this case when you view every
subatomic particle as a satoshi there
are a hundred million satoshis in a
bitcoin
okay
so what you have to do is you have to
take
all of these satoshi's and you have to
identify yourself
as the subatomic particles as the very
fabric of unconditional love light unity
that is the one infinite intelligence at
play in this universe
and then what you can do is you can
recognize that okay this little bundle
of satoshis
we've symbolized with these letters and
now there's been construction
of fortifications of identity that have
reinforced separation
and so then this bundle of satoshis
decentralizes all of those
fortifications of identity that have
been reinforcing separation
and it begins identifying itself again
as the god son
as all bitcoin as all satoshis
and then you fully recognize yourself as
the one infinite intelligence
and that this is all your decentralized
play
and this is a really important
visualization
for awakening this is avalokitesvara
it's a perfect visualization of what
it feels like when you've decentralized
your identity
all the way to being one intelligence
eternally exploring
infinite possibility the only action
that arises is of pure service
the bodhisattva embodying the compassion
of all buddhas
so avalokite is the bodhisattva
embodying the compassion of all buddhas
because it is empty of self because it's
understood
the nature of reality
so in this case what you see here is you
see that you've become life itself look
at all
of the heads you are the pupil when you
look at the pupil itself
that's the one intelligence the power to
know consciousness awareness
beingness that is the power to know that
is what is shared amongst everybody that
is the one infinite creator
wearing these different costumes to play
on the eternal stage
exploring infinite possibility and so
now you've united with this pupil you've
united with the one intelligence that's
shared amongst everyone
and so now you now you are all of those
heads simultaneously
you are all of the arms simultaneously
you are a decentralized you've
decentralized your identity and now you
are that one intelligence
and so now you can't do anything else
except
further empty yourself of all your
conditioning and subconsciousness of all
of those lack beliefs and [ __ ]
and then the only thing that emerges
from there like lao tzu said is wu wei
this effortless action of pure service
that's all that's left buddha
bodhisattva
christ lautza
all of these greatest talked about the
same
thing pure service because you've
emptied yourself
of all of your core lack beliefs and
conditioned [ __ ]
it's beautiful it's absolutely beautiful
it's unbelievable it's indescribably
beautiful
[ __ ] love awakening and it's such a
such a destructive process and i had no
idea
adi ashanti talks about it in the end of
your world
it's such a destructive process it's so
interesting
and you don't really recognize that when
you initially start
but all of the subconscious conditioning
fighting for being seen fighting for
being worthy
is such a losing disastrous chess game
surrender it admit defeat give it up
merge with the god sun and be the
infinite oneness that you've been the
whole time
but that the clouds were just covering
your
full union with it
and join mark's accept yourself program
it's fantastic
the link is there in the bottom left
corner and it's also in the bio
also sign up for bentino massaro and the
no limits society
i've loved working with them they're an
incredible group the link's also in the
bio to that
there's a great process of going through
the know yourself accept yourself
becoming the creator
in the no limit society and
purifying yourself of your conditioning
of all those subconscious
and actualizing a divine calling
people experiencing truth people
experiencing god's
love people knowing themselves as the
one infinite creator
figure out what your calling is all this
good stuff
that's all again identify
what this core lack belief or weakness
is
in your subconscious conditioning and
admit defeat
surrender and merge with the god son
you are automatically worthy being alive
is auto worthiness being alive is
automatically
the god son
i love you thank you
if the video brought you value give it a
like
comment below with where you're at in
the process subscribe to the channel
if you haven't yet
share the video with people that you
feel like it would profoundly influence
great
infinite love infinite oneness
you